all right twitter is combating fake news
with some new features
nbc news uh put up an article there's a
leaked twitter demo
um and they plan on putting
um and let's see they're testing new
ways to fight this
and ben collins says here's what it
might
look like might this is his design
these are screenshots from that were
left on a public testing site twitter
confirm their possible iterations
so these are not official yet but
bernie sand is a bernie sanders suite
that says 40 of the guns in the country
are so without any background checks we
have to end the absurdity of the gun
show loophole harmfully misleading
twitter
community reports have identified this
tweet as violating community policy on
harmful misleading information tweets
visibility or reduce that's bonkers
and this shows you how hard it is to
police
speech yeah like this is not twitter's
job
to do this i mean just from this tweet
this will never work what do you think
wade
you're right you have a platform i'm
glad they're trying yeah
uh it's it's a
herculean task but twitter for so long
had
was just it hadn't changed i hadn't
tried to do anything so
it's i i like seeing technology
companies at least
make an attempt yeah yeah i like that
there's an attempt
to um filter out fake news um
but i don't i i worry that this can be
weaponized by
troll farms of course right because it
is community driven rather than
you know an editorial board or or
something like that
um so i i can see this easily being
weaponized by
by people who have wrong intentions
there's an interesting article
on wikipedia i read a while back i
forget where it was and maybe the new
york times or something like that
where they talked about how wikipedia
has managed to remain
somewhat neutral in a
very in a community different way
because anyone can make changes to
to that and so really dug into how two
polarizing
sets of people can attack a
controversial topic inside a wikipedia
and come out with it
something that reads fairly frequently
because they pause the page they lock it
down
they've got this like cobble of like
early editors who kind of all agree
yeah like librarians i think um the
co-founders larry sanger
and jimmy wells co-founders on wikipedia
um really larry sanger was the person
who
yeah actually came up with the concept
and jimmy wells to credit for it because
he paid for the servers
um just a little point of history and
they lock those pages down those people
are all librarians in that early cohort
they went to
people with library science degrees so
what's actually happened is when a page
gets
you know really controversial they just
lock it down and they don't let
anybody's edits go through yeah and then
if
they they'll unlock it like a month
later if there aren't a bunch of edits
if it happens again they just lock it
down any controversial page and here's
where it gets
when you want to talk about like how
insane it is to try to do this
the potential ui question one given
current evidence is that likely this
tweet contains harmfully missing
information that could cause real world
harm to individuals aside likely harmful
misleading unlikely harmful misleading
question to what percentage of community
members will answer the same as you
the more accurate your answer the more
your report will count
the more you receive question three and
they have a slider from zero to 100
percent
what about this tweet does or does not
make it harmless this is the kind of
interface that's so easy as you're
saying we need to just game yeah you
just
i mean the russians are like thank you
yeah clear shot on goal everything trump
says is 87 percent true everything that
bloomberg says is
14 true uh block her up
isn't this already built into twitter
that you can reply and retweet people
and fact check them
so why not just if i was tweeting what i
do i would hire
a third-party company with 20 like
serious researchers on it make it public
who those researchers were
and then have a twitter account called
at fat fact check
and i would make that count verified i'd
explain what that count does
and i would say every day look at the
trending tweets
and reply to them with a fact check
based on what these 20 people say we we
have gone away from the age
of um respecting
expertise to thinking the crowd knows
better the crowd
does not always know better quotes from
the article disinformation or misleading
information posted by public figures
will be corrected directly beneath the
tweet by fact checkers and journalists
who are verifying the platform and
possibly other users who participated in
the community reports okay well that was
just my idea yeah didn't really know it
again
there you go in one iteration of demo
twitter users your own points and a
community badge if they contribute to
good faith
i would not make this a community thing
i would literally hire 20 experts and
let those people debate it on a
different form
and actually i had this idea i bought
the domain name annotated dot com
and i still own it and my idea was to
just hire 20 fact trackers maybe when i
tire i'll do this
and just have them annotate stuff on the
web they think it's right or wrong
how would you do wade what would you do
here what's your approach do you think
this is going to work you think they're
going to execute on this
you said it's nice they're trying i
agree yeah i i mean
it feels like it gets heavily slanted
towards the majority opinion
like the majority belief will stand out
uh and so it could reduce the voice of
folks who are just simply
underrepresented which
you know i don't know if that's good or
bad it seems like there's we should have
all viewpoints represented here um i
certainly
like the idea of having fact checkers
like little experts that have sort of
you know that are digging into these
topics replying to it so
maybe it helps but i don't know it seems
hard i'm skeptical